that will do that while at the same time
breaking all the rules and having the
dial Rocket architecture that gives it
the flexibility to reach down into that
Leo marketplace and be very competitive
there as well absolutely so we're
getting pretty close to lift now how do
you expect to feel watching the VC
Rocket lift for the first time
tremendous excit and anticipation I got
to tell you I've done over 400 launches
they're all the same i always get
butterflies this one's really special
because of what it means to our country
to our customers and to the team that
has worked so hard including you agent
sterling well thank you so much for
joining us we let you get back to it so
you can make sure you watch liftof and
uh let's go go
van thank
you
on board the Vulcan Rocket today is
astrobotic peragrin commercial Lunar
Lander Perrin is the first spacecraft in
NASA's new clips initiative to have
American companies send science
experiments to the
moon astr is a full serv Lunar company
it starts with our terrestrial testing
and development services that can build
and test propulsion systems on earth to
the sensors that make precision landing
possible to our Rovers that will deploy
down on the surface of the moon the big
thing that we're known for is our two
Lunar missions to go to the surface of
the moon our first one is about to
launch and our second one flies in
2024agr mission is important because
it's first commercial missions to to the
surfaceon this is the dawn of a Newa
ofable roue regular access to the
surfaceagr development was a years long
process that included many people like
engineers welders and technicians who
designed and built the spacecraft to be
on the pad today with our spacecraft
strapped to a giant 200 foot tall launch
vehicle it's a little surreal it's a
moment I've been dreaming about and this
first mission is just our first step to
make space
and11 has been
disbl
Roger also riding atop today's Vulcan
Rocket is the celesus memorial space
flight payload let's learn more about
this
mission Enterprise flight carries
capsules containing cremated remains DNA
samples and greetings from celestus
clients worldwide the capsules are
integrated into two carriers that are
mounted to the forward adapter on ula
centar upper stage the carriers will
remain a fix to ula centar as it travels
into a heliocentric orbit around the sun
where it will remain for eternity the
enterprise flight is celestus first Deep
Space
mission
[Musique]
Flight Control LC go ahead this flight
Control reduceoken hydraulics to stand
by
Roger today's Rocket includes the
American Flag across the interstate
as well as logos on the payload fairing
representing ula Vulc and
astrobotic while this is the inaugural
launch of the Vulcan Rocket the cert one
flight test marks ula's 159th launch
let's learn more about this innovative
new
Rocket
et en fait il
reste euh goock to center L2 at flight
level
Roger terminal count briefing if a
condition exceeds a launch constraint
anytime after the terminal count Status
Check The Observer shall announce hold
hold hold on Channel One identify the
station and briefly state the reason for
the
hold RLM verified Redline monitor and
event table on there configuration for
terminal count
verified as we approach the terminal
count poll
retourner sur la Lune voici la mission
du lancement d'aujourd'hui nous devrions
assister au premier décollage de Vulcane
sansor vers la lune d'ici maintenant une
dizaine de minutes et pour commenter ce
lancement je suis avec Tristan bonjour
Tristan bonjour merci d'être avec nous
aujourd'hui on va commenter ce lancement
vous voyez en haut de de l'image 7
minutes 7 minutes le comptearbourg
devrait démarrer à 8h11 pour un
lancement à 8h18 très précisément
Tristan on retourne sur la lune les
États-Unis vont retourner sur la Lune
avec ce lancement euh oui alors les
États-Unis vontourner sur la Lune en
même temps c'est pas complètement les
États-Unis c'est astroboic donc c'est
une compagnie privée c'est pas un retour
de la NASA sur la lune alors il y a des
il y a des liens avec le programme
de la NASA qui vise à renvoyer des
hommes sur la Lune on pourra on pourra y
revenir là c'est le lancement
atterrissire qui s'appelle pregrine
pèlerin qui est donc le premier
allunisseur de la société
astrobotique qui a un petit allunisseur
qui va pas quelques dizaines de kilos de
charge utile seulement qui de per près
500 kg environ je pas le PO exact mais
c'est la gamme de tous ces allunisseurs
qui sont en fait développé dans le cadre
d'un programme qui s'appelle clsp le
commercial Lunar service payload et en
gros l'idée c'est un peu comme pour le
le le fret à bord de la de la Station
spatiale internationale qui a été
privatisé c'est de de de financer donc à
hauteur de 2,6 milliards de dollars sur
10 ans tout un secteur d'activité donc
il y a pas mal d'entreprises il y a
astrobotique mais il y en aura d'autres
dans les les ben notamment cette année
en fait il y en a pas mal qui sont
prévus déjà cette
année et donc l'objectif pour la NASA
c'est d'essayer de rendre le fret vers
la lune un peu moins cher h en prévision
d'une exploration au long cours d'une
base est-ce que hypothétique base luné
voilà est-ce qu' aujourd'hui on est sur
la première pierre d'une base lunaire
qui serait dans le futur sur la lune
alors pas vraiment sur la première
pierre parce que la charge utile qui va
être envoyée est relativement entre
guillemets sans intérêt c'est c'est
quelques expérience scientifique mené
par la NASA c'est un peu histoire
d'envoyer quelque chose quoi là c'est
vraiment un un un vol de test la
première pierre ce sera le deuxième
lancement d'astrobotique qui est prévu
pour l'instant à la fin de
l'année pas mal de chance pour que il
soit décalé et qu'il là est un
allunisseur lourd qui s'appelle Griffin
euh et et lui va amener en principe un
un Rover qui s'appelle Viper qui fait
500 kg à peu près ou 380 kg enfin un
gros truc comence une belle machine une
belle machine qui va aller au au pôle
Sud euh pour étudier
la présence de glace d'eau dans le
sous-sol et le Pôle Sud c'est l'endroit
où en gros tout le monde voudrait
établir leur base lunaire que ce soit la
Chine ou les États-Unis et parce qu'il y
a la glace d'eau au fond des cratères
que c'est luminé en permanence donc il y
a moins d'écart de température on peut
avoir desister tout le temps avec des
panneaux solaires verticaux par
exemple et donc là ce sera un peu la la
première pierre utile de ce programme au
long cours là aujourd'hui c'est autant
le on dire que là aujourd'hui pour le
lancement le plus important presque
c'est le la réussite de la fusée d'ula
donc Vulcan Cantor qui c'est son vol de
test son premier vol c'est une fusée qui
est destinée à remplacer Delta 4 et
Atlas
5 de pour s'affranchir aussi des moteurs
russes qui était utilisé par ces ces
engins là et donc c'est un moteur blue
origine donc de de la compagnie Jeff
Bezos qui propulse ça c'est ula c'est
leckid Martin et et Boeing donc c'est
c'est un peu le le on va dire c'est
comme nous Arian c'est c'est c'est si tu
ve c'est l'arian américaine quelque part
euh c'est un peu un lanceur voilà
commercial mais destiné à être utilisé
par l'institutionnel et notamment la
NASA et et voilà et c'est c'est c'est
voir si si ce premier lancement se passe
bien pour lui et je pense très important
pour tout le secteur spatial américain
quelque part péregrine qui réussissent
ou qui l'échoue c'est pas très très
important c'est un contrat 80 millions
de dollars pour la NASA bon évidemment
pour astrobotique c'est important je pas
si s'il n'y arrive pas on va voilà ça ce
serait pas mais bon quelque part il
perdrait rien si vousz ils ont déjà été
payés la Nasan table sur une réussite de
50 % VO il y a le lancement voilà c'est
voilà c'est ça le compte àbourg vient de
débuter vous voyez en haut à droite 6
minutes 34 secondes oui arriver à à à à
faire atterrir c'est plus facile de
faire décoller une fusée alors on disait
aujourd'hui 85 % de Chan que ça parte au
à l'instant T c'était il y avait c'était
il y a 20 minutes qu'ils ont annoncé ça
et ensuite 50 % parce que arriver sur la
lune atterrir sur la lune c'est toujours
très compliqué ouais c'est c'est c'est
compliqué mais on a vu récemment la
Russie se cracher à la surface l'année
dernière c'est la société highpace qui
est une petite startup japonaise qui qui
est un peu du du de la même génération
cast robotique en fait c'était l'époque
du Google du Google Lunar x prise je
sais pas si vous vous rappelez de ça
mais c dans les années 2010 Google avait
dit voilà la première aventise privée
qui arrivera aller sur la Lune avec un
Rover et à faire 500 m on lui donne 20
millions de dollars et à l'époque ça
avait nourri pas mal de de petites
boîtes notamment d'émanation
d'université comme astoboutique qui est
une émanation de l'université Carn
guimelon à de Pittsburg et ça
avait voilà alimenté on va dire toute
une effervescence autour de de de ce
programme
un petit lanceur avec des petits Rover
et cetera çaavait pas débouché
finalement il y a eu des des on dire
défis intermédiaire qui avait été qui
avait été validé mais personne
évidemment on s'en rappellerait n'avait
réussi à aller sur la
Lune et du coup le programme s'arrête en
2018 ce concours s'arrête en 2018 et en
2019 la NASA lance son commercial
service Lunar P et CP commercial Lunar
on s'en fiche et et à partir de là elle
prend le relais entre guillemets de ce
Google x prise et elle finance à hauteur
à près de 80 millions
chaque chaque chaque boîte quoi qui va
développer son al sélectionne
quelquesuns et mais c'est du c'est de
l'investissement enfin c'est du mescena
on vous donne de l'argent gratuitement
ou est-ce qu'on ou est-ce que c'est du
mescena mais c'est surtout pour que bah
le spatial il y ait une concurrence il y
a des choses qui se passent dans le
spatial et et la nada se doit de mettre
des sous pour ça les deux les deux en
fait en gros l'idée c'est d'essayer de
créer une économie lunaire autour de la
Lune et autour du fret lunaire sachant
que il y a pas vraiment de débouché
économique actuellement alors des
entreprises essay d' d'en trouver la
péregrine il va emporter quelques
petites capsules temporelles qu'ils ont
vendu je sais plus combien le quel est
le prix mais il y a un prix au kilogram
si vous voulez donc il y a des a desè
d'œuvres miniatures qui vont être envoyé
dans des capsules temporelles des choses
comme
ça bon assez symbolique mais qui qui
permet de donner une activité je pense
pas que ça suffise à générer une
activité au long en cours le le le le la
vraie opportunité qu'on peut voir c'est
effectivement de fournir du maternel à
des astronautes qui iraient quiirait à
la surface ou de fournir des des robots
pour
l'exploration encore une fois c'est un
peu c'est un peu comme pour l'ISS si
vous voulez on on on a besoin d'envoyer
des astronutes dans l'ISS et on a créé
l'ISS pour avoir des besoins dans les
des astronautes quelque part donc il y a
un peu cette même logique pour la
on crée une économie de fr lunaire et
après on envoie des astronautes parce
qu'on a besoin Deir économie qui ont
besoin des astronautes et cetera après
aller sur la Lune c'est plutôt pour
l'instant quelque chose de
symbolique évidemment il y a l'idée d'en
faire une base avancée pour
l'exploration plus lointaine en
récupérant la glace d'eau en fabriquant
des agoles on gagnerait beaucoup en
terme énergétique pour aller plus loin
dans le système solaire mais à quel
échéant c'est ça ça on ça on n est pas
encore dans les 5 à 10 ans non non non
ce sera plutôt 2050 2060 2070 je sais
pas exactement mais après c'est
comme le spael actuellement il il a ça
ceci d'intéressant qui il y a des
ruptures notamment bah SpaceX en on a un
bon exemple ils ont ils ont apporté une
première rupture avec le le réutilisable
et et le programme clsp se nourrit de ça
la là c'est c'est lancé par
c'est un vol c'est le premier vol donc
probablement moins cher si ce n gratuit
je sais pas ex combien pgrine si pgrine
a payé ou non pour pour être en haut
c'est pas évident qu'il a payé pour un
vol pour un vol
inaugural et du coup SpaceX la plupart
des autres sont lancé par SpaceX parce
que c'est moins cher et que ça permet
justement à ces entreprises d'avoir un
coût
réduit c'est falconemportera les le
Griffin donc voilà c'est un peu le et
voilà SPX pour objectif de de réussire
son Starship donc c'est un vaisseau
énorme qui oui on l'a vu qu'il a pas
forcément très bien réussi d'ailleurs
cette année ni bien ni mal on va dire on
est dans la la courbe d'apprentissage à
peu près anticipé de pH c'est compliqué
pour les gens de le comprendre mais
c'est des échecs qui étaient
relativement attendus en fait la
question c'est de savoir jusqu'où ils
vont aller avant d'échouer et à chaque
fois ils ont progressé ils ont pas
explosé sur le pas de tir elle a f s
envolé elle a plutôt bien répondu la
première fois la deuxième fois elle a
fait un vol
relativement long euh voilà c'est c'est
plutô la courbe d'apprentissage quoi le
le jour elle explose sur le plat de tir
elle explose tout Starship est peut-être
mort c'est ça qui le rend le truc à la
fois excitant et imprévisible c'est que
si le pas tir explose à la prochaine
c'est peut-être la fin de Starship en
même temps s'il réussissent un truc
super bien ça peut être le début d'une
nouvelle aventure spatial parce que les
capacités d'emport sont tellement plus
phénoménales que que ça change tout oui
par rapport à une à une fusée comme ça
alors que là le le le décollage j'ai
prévu d'ici une minute euh la fusée
Starship est beaucoup peut amener
beaucoup plus de choses que cette fusée
vu le 400 ans sans sans comparaison
d'accord alors on va on va suivre ce
lancement d'ici 54 secondes vous le
voyez sur votre écran ce décollage qui
va avoir lieu est-ce qu'on sait dans
combien de temps elle arrivera sur la
lune euh la sonde je crois que
l'atterrissage est prévu le 23 février
alors après elle arrivera peut-être
avant le voyage est pas aussi long que
ça pour aller vers la lune elle va se
mettre en orbite probablement prendre
des prendre son temps pas de il y a pas
a pas on y va pas pour pour se poser
direct on se met en orbite on tourne un
peu autour et au bout d'un moment on se
pose au
ou effement on suit on suit ce lancement
qui a lie de nuit aussi lancement de
nuit on va suivre d'ailleurs les 15
dernières secondes on va vous laisser
vivre ce
décollage
and lift of the first United launch
alliance VC Rocket launching a new era
and space flight to the moon and
beyond two good SRB hitting peak
pressure on the
SRBs everything looking
good
tout se passe bien pour le décollage a
priori trist t t comme prévu oui oui
tout l'air nominal pour l'instant c'est
toujours un peu étonnant de voir
decoller une nouvelle fusée parce qu'on
sait pas exactement à quoi
s'attendre même visuellement ça ça
paraissait comme oncoup d'étincell
beaucoup d'étincelles un
panache assez particulier après c'est de
nuit donc ça dépend aussi beaucoup des
des caméras mais on est bon après on est
sur une propulsion je crois au méthane
comme comme les comme les fus SpaceX
moteur méthane
oxygène
par c'est c'est un lancement de nuit on
le disait SP plutôt l'habitude on a
l'impression de faire décoller ses fusé
en journée
pour faire pour qu'on voit bien le fusé
décoll on direu l'impression de
ça
une vraiment le moment du
lancement du de la mission des
boost et
oui oui non c'est c'est c'est purement
euh dépendant euh du programme de vol il
y a absolument un lancement de de nuit
est super impressionnant voir au
crépuscule et après SpaceX il lance
tellement tellement tellement ils on là
il prévoit cette année je crois une
centaine de lancement c'est écoutez
c'est totalement euh dingue
euh la le le le le le le spatial va
encore accélérer en 2024 la la conquête
de la Lune va encore accélérer en 2024
alors pour ce qui de la conquête de la
lune donc il y a ce programme clsp là de
de la data dont je vous parlais qui donc
investit euh depuis 2018 2019 environ
dans le secteur et et cette année on
voit un peu la concrétisation de
différents projets il y a intuitive
machines qui va suivre qui va lancer
pareil c'est un petit allunisseur pour
sa sa première mission euh il y a un
petit bouchon parce que la C machines
avaient trois euh lancements de prévus
pour le compte de la NASA
et ils sont pour l'instant tous les
trois prévus en 2024 alors est-ce qu'ils
ça paraît quand même peu probable qu'il
qu'ils arrivent à tout lancer euh euh
tout va dépendre aussi la réussite du
premier ou non euh mais peut-être
peut-être deux lancementstive machines
euh il y a high space donc c'est la
japonaise qui doit revenir en vol aussi
à la fin de l'année il y a une troisième
entreprise dont le nom m'échappe Aerojet
ou euh bon le nom méchappe mais qui va
aussi lancer son petit euh
son petit son alumissur qui doit faire
son vol son premier vol cette année
voilà il y a toute
une un ensemble de sociétés qui arrivve
à qui arrivrive à maturité autour du
sujet en plus de ça il y a la deuxième
mission Artémis qui sera lancée à la fin
de l'année donc avec des astronautes qui
vont aller faire un tour autour de la
Lune sans sans se poser sans se poser
voilà sera la première le premier vol
habité de la capsule Orion de la NASA
pour le coup lancé par la fusée de la
NASA SLS euh qui a là pour le coup un
peu un mastodonte un peu comme la fusée
comme la fusée qui avait envoyé les
hommes sur la Lune
euh
et en plus de ça qu'est-ce qu'il va y
avoir il y a la le Japon qui va tenter
de se poser
là dans début février je CIS non fin
janvier en 19 200 janvier c'est un petit
un
atterrisseur de haute précision fabriqué
par la JAXA donc l'agence spatiale
japonaise il y a la Chine qui va euh
lancer sa mission de retour
d'échantillon de la face cachée en mai
en
principe voilà ça fait une année une
année chargée en tout il y a pour
l'instant il y a une une petite dizaine
de
missions au
calendrier avec les reports qu'on peut
attendre de celles qui sont en fin
d'année je dirais qu'il y en aura au
moins 6 se qui vont voler quasiment
sûr c'est déjà beaucoup l'année dernière
il y en avait trois euh
et et voilà et d'après les manifestes on
est à peu près sur le même rythme
l'année
prochaine après les les grandes étapes
du programme Artémis comp la séparation
se passe
bien tout SEM se passer de façon
nominale comme on dit dans le dans le
jargon
exactement donc là voilà ce qu'on voit
c'est évidemment pas des images de la
fusée paril fa une fusée pour les filmer
mais on est pas en image de synthèse
V passe synthèse et et là en fait ce que
suivent les les les ingénieurs si vous
êtes curieux mais en gros ils suivent
une trajectoire nominale et et ils
regardent la télémétrie qui donne la
position exacte du exact à peu près
exact du vaisseau grâce au radar au sol
enoufin aux antennes au sol
et et on regarde si la trajectoire suit
ce qui était prévu et si si on Sass ce
qui était prévu puis on a les capteurs
pour les les moteurs et cetera pour tout
ça sachant qu'on imagine que si la
trajectoire dévie un tout petit peu
c'est la fin de la mission ou euh alors
tout dépend qu'onelle un tout petit peu
sielle devient un tout petit peu non ça
peut poursuivre il faut juste corriger
probablement un peu la la
trajectoire de de la fusée donc ça peut
vouloir dire B pas mal de choses mais on
peut toujours corriger un peu la
trajectoire nominale plus on est proche
en plus on économise de carburant c'est
une question sur cette question là donc
ça peut permettre si on a un satellit
par exemple qui doit effectuer quelques
manœvres pour se mettre sur son orbite
si on l'injecte avec plus de précision
il va avoir moins de manœuvre à
effectuer donc du coup il va garder plus
de carburant et du coup il pourra avoir
une durée de vie plus longue pour un
vaisseau spatialfin une d'exploration
planétaire c'est pareil ça pe lui
permettre d'étendre sa durée de vie de
mission en économisant du carburant sur
sur ces
dernières voilà c'est un peu ça le
l'enjeu si elle dévie assez largement en
fonction de si ça présente un risque ou
pas on peut procéder la destruction de
la fusée ça c'est g la première minute
de vol 2 minutes de
vol en général quand elle
est est là bou de 7 minutes de vol en
général il il peut plus rien se passer
jusqu'à arriver autour de la Lune enfin
en tout cas peut toujours se passer
quelque chose parce que il faut quand
même que la poussée a lieu jusqu'au bout
là le l'étageint en train de pousser et
cetera mais on va dire qu'à priori c'est
une phase Mo critique une phase moins
critique vous le comprenez vous avez
suivi ce lancement de la Vulc sentor
parler des des arrivées sur la lune
est-ce que les États-Unis sont toujours
la plus grande on par par de la Chine du
Japon est-ce que les États-Unis sont
toujours le leader du spatial dans le
monde oui sans trop
de dire presque sans trop de de
concurence c'est une question de budget
le budget alloué par la les États-Unis
au spatial est
considérable je sais plus je crois que
c'est plus de 10 fois le budget
européen c'est largement super ce que
consacre la Chine
aussi néanmoins la Chine suit un
programme notamment d'exploration
lunaire ils ont aussi le leur propre
station spatiale
habité donc voilà ils sont ils ont ils
sont clairement largement devant
l'Europe en terme de de de compétenence
pour le ce qui est du valabité de
l'exploration
proche l'Europe est plus spécialisée
dans l'exploration lointaine avec des
des grosses de robotique des instruments
scientifiques de bien meilleure qualité
et cetera il y a des domaines dans
lesquel l'Europe est meilleure mais pour
ce qui est de l'exploration habité la
Chine est est clairement je dirais
aujourd'hui en deuxè position derrière
les États-Unis et devant la
Russie c'est parce que l'Europe s'est
spécialisée dans un autre segment parce
qu'elle n'arrivait pas à suivre
ou le c'est des choix stratégiques qui
ont été fait quand il y a arien 5 qui
Aren 5 éit une fusée qui avait vocation
à emporter euh une navette spatiale
hermè pour emporter des astronautes et
voilà ça coûtait cher et l'Europe a jugé
trop cher et et du coup le programme a
été abandonné donc c'est c'est un choix
stratégique hein rien n'aurait empêcher
de faire voler des astronautes avec
Arian et il y a certaines personnes qui
veulent faire
revivre ça donner une capacité à
l'Europe d'exploration pour l'instant le
le le choix stratégique de l'Europe
c'est plutôt de se de miser sur
l'exploration euh enfin sur la
l'observation de la Terre et
l'exploration robotique euh euh et les
instruments euh euh type déteecteur d'
gravitationnel ou télescopees spatiaux
euh pour faire de la science et de
s'adosser aux États-Unis en fournissant
pour ce qui est de la capsule orayon du
du d'Artémis de du programme Artémis
l'Europe fournit un ce qu'on appelle un
un un module de service en gros c'est ce
qui aaché derrière la capsule et qui
fournit la propulsion l'air l'eau
l'électricité euh euh et ça garantit des
places à des astronautes européens à
bord de la capsule Orion pour les
missions donc Artémis 3 et 4 je crois il
il y aura un Européen à bord de
chat
euh et fa que je vérifie pour
Artéis 3 je sais plus sûr mais aussi
peut-être pour Artéis 3 on n pas de pied
sur la Lune garantie pour l'instant
d'accord vous voyez donc alors que on
nous demande on nous demande F demande a
eu lieu le décollage je suis désolé de
vous annoncer qu'il a eu lieu le
décollage on va vous le repasser il a eu
lieu tout à l'heure on on va vous le
montrer hop
attendez ce décollage qui a eu lieu il y
a maintenant une une dizaine une dizaine
de minutes l'Europe vous en parlez avec
Arian 5 il y a Arian 6 qui arrive et qui
se fait attendre qui se fait attendre
qui s'est fait attendre on va dire parce
que les retards ont été pris il y a un
moment déjà depuis quelques temps on va
dire qu'on on suit à peu
près le calendrier enfin il a il y a il
y a des y a des petits retards de
quelques mois mais qui sont on va dire
qu'on peut attendre dans ce type de
développement de de fusée les gros
retards ont été pris à il y a quelques
années déjà pendant le développement où
là on a pris des années de retard
quelques années de retard le lancement
est prévu le premier lancement est prévu
le 15 juin euh avec voilà l'espo
que que c'est soit pas le 15 juin ce
soit ce soit on va dire le courant de
l'été voilà c'est un premier vol
inaugural qui va être très
important parce que attend du tournant
qui a un carnet de commande qui commence
à se remplir voir une file d'attente qui
commence à se créer parce qu'il on a
plus d'aren 5 donc le le lanceur est est
très attendu que soit pour les besoins
institutionnels on a AR 62 qui serait un
peu qui permettrait de remplacer so
Paron l'Europe lançait quand même une
version de soy depuis la Guyane une
version va dire européenne de de soy
depuis la
Guyane ça l'arrê du partenariat avec les
Russes forcément dans le
spatial rabattu les cartes complètement
ouais ouais ça a un peu rebattu les
cartes pour l'Europe ça ça ça ça
compliqué on avait une mission martienne
prévue en partenar avec la Russie donc
ça NOTAM la Russie le vaisseau pour se
poser euh voilà doncant il faut trouver
un nouveau vaisseau pour se poser donc
on pas fait le rover mais elle a pas le
le vaisseau on a perdu les capacités
d'emport de soy donc un lanceur moyen
qui était très utilisé pourir peêtre
l'un des plus lancés par par Espace donc
voilà il faut remplacer ça par vegac par
AR 6
oui ça a changé pas mal pas mal de
choses c'est SR merci beaucoup en tout
cas trist en d'avoir été avec nous a
priori tout se passe bien pour ce pour
ce lancement n sommes 13 minutes après
le décollage et là comme on le disait
c'est la partie compliqué qui est passé
il y aura l'autre partie compliquée qui
sera la lunissage mais ça on l' dit ce
sera d'ici un mois et demi finalement
donc on a un peu le temps ouais ça on a
un peu le temps mais on se retrouve pour
le lunissage le 23 février allez on fera
ça merci Tristan Merci à VOUS du Figaro
d'avoir été nombreux à nous suivre et
moi je vous dis à bientôt pour de
nouveau live sur Figaro
live minutes left uh here in the um the
first the stage we coast for about 30
minutes after that we that uh that Coast
across Atlantic Ocean and across Africa
the second burn will be about 4 minutes
long then we have another coast for 30
minutes before we have a pretty short
second once done
that engineeringos we to do before we
finally safe the stage and SH everything
off and then about days later is when
the
leave the earth Moon system and be
wayepace AWESOME well thank you so much
for sharing that with us and thanks for
for joining us today and uh we'll let
you get back to to watching those next
events absolutely thanks so much Amanda
thanks pu system is stead making the
correction down to a nominal
Mr
[Musique]
or one minute
too both engins firing
normally
NASA team toue with mission coverage
through the Coase we join you back in as
we approach the separation of the paragr
spacecraft over to you Megan thank you
congratulations to you